good morning believe nation today's
message is know your mission over the
youth drive my CEO in 1994 I was telling
people only this weekend in Washington
70% of the African people in 1994 had
never heard a telephone ring and it said
used one I said they'd never heard it
ring that was a human need I knew as a
young engineer not long since my college
days that we could change that we had
the technology to do it the resources
were out there
it was a human need when you wake up and
say we want to make billions of dollars
we said we want to extend
telecommunications to all the peoples of
Africa and I wrote it on our boards and
I told our people and I said our mission
is to provide telecommunications to all
the people of Africa people want to wake
up and go to work and feel like the work
that they're doing matters right you
want your life and your work to have
meaning you spend so much time working
every day that you want to feel like the
stuff that you're doing you're waking up
to go to do every single day matters and
that's not just for your team that's for
you right yes you want your employees to
wake up and feel like they're doing
something important but you too right
and if you don't have a team yet you
want to feel like every day the thing
that you're about to do today makes a
difference in somebody's life you're on
an important mission and whenever you
feel down or depressed or upset and you
feel like maybe you shouldn't do this
anymore maybe this isn't the right
business for you the thing that keeps
you going the thing that gets you
through those hard times is that
important mission that you are
on my mission is the help of billion
entrepreneurs fuels me it drives me it's
why I wake up every day it's why I make
these videos for you and so my question
today for you is what is your mission
leave it in the comments below and I'm
gonna Jordan the discussion thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso